hello everybody and welcome to another
video today I'm going to be showing off
another moneymaking method uh it's
really easy to do all you really need is
a grand exchange and yeah what we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
combining items into item sets uh so
barrows items into barrows sets uh
trimmed armor to trim set stuff like
that and yeah so we have G Tracker open
here uh it's kind of useful if you have
uh G tracker um for the actual estimated
profits on the S but if not you can
actually easily calculate them yourself
you just take the set price and reduce
off the individual item
pieces um so yeah it's pretty easy to
calculate but um having that information
readily available is also kind of nice
too so it looks like we're going to get
200 to 300K on the rim set by combining
it so we're going to go basically into
each piece uh individually look at the
prices come up with an offer price uh
for all four pieces and then afterwards
we'll combine them uh so we'll start
with the rims Hood it looks like it's
going to go in for about 68k uh just
basic based on the average actively
trade price and the g g Tracker price uh
after that we're moving on to all the
other pieces uh so we'll come up with a
price for each one and yeah we'll come
back when the items have bought okay and
just to clarify we're just going to do
each individual piece I decided actually
uh so the rims robe top we're going to
put in for
1090k and move on to the next one and
the robe skirt we're going to put in for
885k um again just from a g Tracker
price notice we already bought the rims
R Top so only have a minute to buy that
one so far and then we're just going to
move on to the last item the rim staff
which conveniently is actually the
cheapest one uh so we're not actually
putting it in for the low price on any
of these items we're putting in for a
higher uh maybe not the high price like
we're not instantly buying all the
things but we're putting in for much of
a higher price than um than we could and
this is just for the sake of speed and
uh it doesn't really reduce your margin
that much and yeah we're on to the last
item we'll probably just plop in there
for about 70k and oh yeah I remember now
actually in recently bought this item uh
which is totally fine cuz we're only
going to lose a couple couple thousand
in the margin U but yeah anyway we'll
come back when the uh set has totally
bought okay there we go we bought all
the items um probably took six or 7
minutes maximum probably like five for
the whole process uh so yeah all you do
is once you have your items you're going
to remove them uh talk to the Grand
exchange lady uh go to the sets option
and then you're just going to click on
the only UNH highlighted set available
I'm going to combine it into a set for
you and then you're just going to set
sell it back I think we're going to sell
it for about 238k as what we looked at G
tracker somewhere around there that's
going to give us about 250k margin uh
which is still quite nice okay so we
ended up having to lower the rim set a
little bit uh we had it in there for
about 3 minutes and then we just kind of
decided that it was not selling and
there we go it sold uh so that was just
the actively traded price so we're kind
of just picking a kind of medium between
the two but yeah there we go that's
about 250k main profit right there so
somebody in the last episode actually
suggested I put a timer uh with the clip
and this is a clip where I actually made
500k in about 20 minutes uh so you can
see we popped in the offer it's the
exact same as one as the first time we
did it we instantly bought the rim staff
again and yeah we'll just leave this
running for a little bit and come back
when we bought most of the items okay so
we're just kind of popping back in here
we have bought the majority of the items
we need another rims hood and a rim
staff uh now just keep in mind we're
buying these for the exact same price is
the first clip so we're g to get 250k in
profit per uh per set and we have two of
these here giving us about 500k uh we're
just getting down to the 20 minute Mark
and you can see these items do buy
really quickly any of the Barrow sets um
buy and sell quite quick see look there
we got the rim staff I always have to
wait on the Rim's Hood but I mean you
could okay there we go so it's all
bought perfect so now we're going to hit
up the exchange lady again and just get
our sets done and then we're going to
pop them back in for 2362 and that is
leaving us with about a 250k profit per
set and yeah we'll see how quickly
managed to sell okay good uh took a good
4 minutes to sell the first Set uh so
not too bad the first time I did it sold
a little bit quicker uh about 20 or 30
sell an hour so it can be a little hit
and miss but honestly it shouldn't take
too long down to about 15
minutes uh the next set should sell any
second now and that will leave us with a
500K profit now you can do this with any
item you don't have to do with the rim
set u this just happened to be the most
profit Li at the time okay and at 13
minutes we sold the second set and that
is it guys that's 500k in total all
right guys that is it I hope you enjoyed
the video again if you want to look up
the website I was using to check the
prices as well as the uh moneymaking
methods that was showing uh a link will
be in the description and yeah I hope
you guys enjoyed and I'll see you guys
in the next
[Music]
video